mentioned you guys were with Steven
Seagal yeah
[Applause]
[Applause]
how was he taken to uh Islam at all or
have you guys had a discussion about it
yeah Steve let's go and I also believe
that right should triumph over evil
similarly I know there's a stigma about
him in those West and he had a lot of uh
controversy surround him but he's
honestly a nice guy very straightforward
very old school kind of alpha male and
he respects it he says he lives in
Russia in Russia if you're going to get
a country which is close to a Muslim
State and I don't offend anyone I'm not
saying about their political alliances
I'm saying Russian Orthodox Christians
are very similar in a way uh the
households the respect they have for
those ones um
the they don't like
entertaining certain kind of agendas
being pushed in their country is very
very similar I've been to Moscow many
times so he's based in he likes that
system and he when we speak he agrees
with everything he he understands he
understands why he's Muslim and he says
I understand I've been to the West I've
been to America they've killed religion
they're trying to put religion in a draw
right and those religions have molded to
it and they want basically the dollar or
democracy I don't know what they're
trying to push the agenda but that
religion keep it at home keep it during
I don't know their Christmas or their
Sunday gospel but it's not for society
whereas he he thinks otherwise and uh
yeah he respects a lot and um honestly
I've
there's not many people I've been around
in my life when you speak to my right
they don't respect it uh
there's many who even inshallah I mean
Andrew's brother respects it a lot
inshallah one day hopefully he's a very
good guy as well himself Tristan very
straightforward good guy
um they've been raised well you can see
and you never know in Shalom because uh
when you have an older brother who you
respect to look up to as well and they
go a certain way I know usually the
younger brothers kind of follow him
apart so who knows but um
I think uh
what he's done is very good
for our younger youth in a way I'm not
saying he's going to be a role model
because our role model should always be
the prophet peace be over hunting but
these young guys who I feel feel ashamed
to be Muslim want to impress too much or
it's prayer time I can't pray in front
of them this girl might think I'm this
or this guy
he's put in a shame to that